can you talk about a defining moment
where
you said now i have an acting career
this this is where i've crossed over
was this a certain role that you booked
was it a
mindset that you adopted
i do remember i'm just going to answer
like what came to my mind because that's
usually like the most honest you know
the first thing that comes up
uh i booked like my first
off-broadway show in new york right
after i graduated from college and
uh the donkey show
and um when i was hired i mean it was
definitely like a whole process of
auditioning auditioning call back call
back audition
um and i remember getting the call and i
got so much encouragement and like oh my
god you're gonna be a star this is
this is crazy i can't you booked it you
beat all these people out who've been in
new york for a while and i've just been
there for a couple months so it was like
a
uh an exciting like super exciting and
knowing that i just i booked you know
this gig that became a really popular
show for like two years
in new york um
yeah that was a that was definitely a
defining moment i had a lot of people
that saw me even to this day that
out here all run into like oh my god i
saw that show you know so
that's what i would mention
you